about doing this film because it touches
on something that everybody's very
sensitive about anything that's very
culturally relevant towards like you
know black Americans you just have to
like it and if you say otherwise people
will get upset about it yeah even if we
do it from a film perspective right but
I I get it in five
four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we have Ed Park VP here
that is his Instagram handle cheers once
again
shooting some podcast episodes back to
back if you guys don't know we don't
shoot these uh concurrently we just do
it in a row and then we release it when
we can there was a topic that people
wanted us to talk about but it's
honestly a case that I really don't give
a [__] about
um it was the the murder murder case
right right which apparently
it this case has been ongoing for a
little bit right like five weeks or
something like that it might maybe a
little more but [__] already
put like Netflix documentaries about it
it's been all over people I'm like
that's [__] insane and they just had
the trial right yeah but then like they
put out the documentary
right which is weird yeah I don't
understand that but like every murder
document that I've seen it's like things
that happen like thoroughly investigated
and it's happened like 10 years ago or
five years ago three years ago yeah how
do you put out a documentary where
something's still going on out right now
I guess the rules for documentary
journalism has changed because of the
streaming system it's like as if okay we
will just put it out now while it's hot
or whatever in the news then we'll have
a follow-up episode you know once the
trial happens or some [__] like that
maybe that's the case because with
streaming [__] like you could treat it
like as if it's television it's not like
it takes super long to produce a film
um like the the way you do a documentary
maybe it's just changed the way [__] is
done because of streaming I just feel
that way up this is the only thing that
I wanted to talk about with this thing
this subject is that I don't understand
and once again I'm not minimizing the
tragedy that happened only because I'm
talking about things in the sense of
when we talk about murder court cases or
something atrocious that's happened in
the news yeah
um it's like stuff that's almost unheard
of right right but it's about a man who
he is he was born into wealth I believe
is what I've read so he has all this
money but he was like siphoning money
out of his Corporation he's a lawyer I
believe like millions of dollars which I
think it's pretty common case that you
hear stuff like that and he murders his
wife and his and his kid this is
horrendous stuff but it was the thing
that everybody was talking about
and once again I'm not minimizing how
tragic this is I just don't understand
why this case became the biggest thing
that was like the Talk of the Town right
it it became like
I don't know how do you put it like OJ
yeah yeah yeah like I don't know I don't
know the who's the other killer Ramsay
or yeah all these things like we have
this obsession with these certain
murders in our country yeah that like
really fascinates our entry like with
like how we want to know more and what
happened and all these things like why
do we become obsessed with these
tragedies I don't know but this is what
we were kind of mentioning too where um
I don't know if it's like my criticism
of once again this is a reoccurring
topic that I'll always keep saying is
kind of what media does now where
I I now have to question even people in
my peer group as to why they do things
right do you do things because it's
something that you enjoy doing or
because it's the experience or do right
before you do it and you hit that record
button do you say this is going to be
good content
so I've tweeted this recently where I
was asking people like when did it
become socially acceptable for people to
always express and show people when
they're crying thank you
when yeah I don't know what to do when I
see someone crying on my feed like what
is this like what and this is why I'm
saying and you know somebody who
actually wrote a comment they go I do it
because I want people to feel like
they're not alone that's [__] I call
[__] on that a hundred percent so
when you feel this emotion right you're
about to cry you have to stop you have
to do this hold on
all right
that's what you have to do yeah I call
[__] on that right and then I just
want everyone out there you're home
you're not alone you're not alone no no
no no no no no no no no no let's be
honest I think look whatever your
motivation for what you're doing I get
it right but the one thing I dislike is
a dishonesty to say like it makes me
feel good when people give me that
thumbs ups and like because I'm feeling
sad so it does something for me yeah I
think that's very bad but at least
you're being honest about it like don't
do it as if your virtue signaling to
everybody about how amazing you are as a
person because you're doing this because
you're the you're the guy or girl that's
gonna get everybody to understand that
they're not alone no you're doing it
because you want other people to make
you feel better and then Pat you on the
back it's inherently selfish thing that
you're doing here right that's okay just
if you're honest about it yeah just be
honest about it don't do that type of
[__] I need the likes all right I
respect that yeah don't don't
rationalize your weird narcissism you
know what I mean yeah but I I wrote this
because I saw this video
um We're not gonna put this person on
blasting but there's no point in hurting
people like that but this girl she put
up this video right and in the caption
and there was a voiceover for this as
well of course because voiceovers are
the hottest thing right now she goes I
never get to see my grandmother so now
when she makes me food I understand that
I have limited time with her and she's
bawling on camera and is set up in the
corner of this camera right now
I'm thinking positive things first I'm
like okay she set up that camera
and she was just going to show a video
of her eating with her grandma here's
the thing there was four angles
there were four [__] angles four and
I guarantee you
she did not have four iPhones yeah she
didn't have four spontaneous recordings
so she did she had a tripod she set it
up she crying she stop set up another
angle continue to cry
okay and she goes back to her seat
starts eating the food in front of her
grandma stops
it goes back as
it's come on was the background music
the theme song from Up
[Laughter]
I was like At first I was like oh that's
kind of waiters wait wait wait a second
it's four angles do you know what it is
man we're in production the veils are
torn we know what's going on behind
behind the curtain like think about when
we watch movies and this is what other
people say and I don't know slash
complain about me is that when I'm
watching a movie I'll notice the little
edits the little the little flaws in it
like something weird about that angle
like oh did you see that cut something
like that and then
I realized when I'm watching a movie I
I'm seeing it through the process of it
being produced right and so the curtains
come up and we see how the strings are
being pulled and so now when we see
these [__] bunk ass social media
posts are like
come on like well that's why I you know
I see the practicality of how you had to
get that done like I did this video
about you know on Instagram every now
and then like I'll just go back to my
old rant videos that I used to do on
YouTube I just do it on Instagram now
yeah
um just because there's a lot faster I
don't have to do a lot of high
production with it right
and it was this guy out in the middle of
the street he's this Australian dude in
the busy street right
he's outside he has a sign that says I
suffer from anxiety and depression and I
need somebody to talk to me which I've
suffered from anxiety my whole life that
is my worst [__] nightmare to stand
in the middle of a street with a sign
and tell people your fears yes
but it says talk to strange and the
Multiverse of Madness
hey idiot messed up with anxiety is yeah
the exact opposite if you had that's my
worst [__] nightmare I would now I
know how to control it but when I was
you know when I had my social anxiety
was out of control that would be
something I would dream about that would
make me wake up and sweat right you know
and then he flips over this sign right
which clearly people can see from the
other side where there's money attached
here and it says free money and you can
see in the video people going oh this
[__] got money attack you know
who doesn't want and he turns around and
he's chastising people basically saying
that they're evil people because they're
walking up to him when he has a sign
that says free money who the [__]
wouldn't come up to you and take the
free money idiot turn it over again and
say free Xanax yeah
oh there goes you're excited
I don't know man what do you want the
video didn't make sense it just doesn't
make sense at all in any type of [__]
level you know what I'm saying it's the
stupidest social experiment the new
brownie points but we've seen it all all
our lives growing up in church right oh
yeah that's right it's like oh my God
has social media become Church culture
oh my God of this front of like how how
awesome or how you know I don't know
healthy or wait awoke and aware you are
I'll tell you this the reason why I
dislike videos like that is because
I'm not sure if you guys feel this way
or if you agree
there's so many bad things happening in
this world
right so much bad [__]
what are you doing what is the message
that you're sending out humans are all
trash is this the video that you're
putting out right now
in this world full of disasters people
being murdered we have gun control
issues in this country all this other
stuff of real life issues and then
you're out there with a [__] sign
saying I need my anxiety yeah [__] you
crane
anxiety like what was the purpose of
that video the purpose of the video is
him saying that human beings are trash
that is not a good video
we live in a society a joker yeah
because there was a girl who wrote in a
comment and she goes the point of the
video is like you're missing the point
of the video I was like no you're
missing the point of the video yeah he
did that video to highlight how good of
a person he is and how everybody else is
trash
that's the point of the video Yeah
conversely there's somebody else on
Instagram that I [__] love this guy
makes me cry every time I watch his
videos he comes up to a person he goes
hey can I have a dollar right and the
person and stuff gives him a dollar and
they you know they're busy doing their
own things he goes hey because you're a
good person you did something nice for
me I want to reward you and they touch
telling like I've had a rough time that
has a great message right and amazing it
shows Humanity it shows kindness it
shows love I think that's what that
[__] idiot was trying to do yeah but
he did in the worst [__] way he's
trying to teach a lesson that's not fair
exactly yeah that guy's videos I [__]
love because it makes me believe that
humans are really kind right and he ends
up like giving a thousand like Canadian
dollars or something right like I saw
one where he tried to give up Frozen
mittens or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean he has weird premises sometimes
but then he finds like these diamond and
the rough people in our society there
was a video that he put out that made me
feel so good because there was a guy I
was locking out and it was a Super Bowl
right and then you know he goes uh he
was like either trying to get a dollar
or something else or whatnot and then oh
it was a football he goes oh you want
this football blah blah blah and he goes
oh yeah go take it he goes oh and he
takes him to the Super Bowl right right
and dude you saw the joy and it was like
something he's dreamed of his whole
[__] life that guy is making a
difference in somebody's life that guy
the other dude is pointing like a false
mirror you're like at other people like
you're setting people up you jackass
yeah like this guy when I saw that dude
one side would have been like you know
like support dying children starving
children in Africa and the other side
could have said free money it's like
literally the same thing it's just two
different things like how are you saying
oh these people like money more because
over this issue but the funny thing is
it wasn't about someone else's problems
in the world it was about his anxiety
exactly exactly
so I roasted this video and everybody
understood too they got it except for a
couple of people they're like oh his
message was positive I was like no it
wasn't if it was positive I would have
made fun of this video I would have made
a comedic video about that I still keep
thinking about like maybe he has one his
Sciences I suffer from narcissist
disorder perfect perfect you know like
give me attention give me attention oh
my God you need to go out on the streets
to do that I'm gonna do that [__] it's
like I'm a great person you need to talk
to me
and then I'll end it with the video
saying like when I had a sign that said
people should talk they never did yeah
but the other sign said I was getting
the free blow jobs and they kept trying
to take me to their car
you want the most annoying part of that
video is he dropped the sign like it was
a my drop
Society hey guys huh look at us yeah for
some reason I had a sign that said free
blow jobs and they kept trying to push
my head down to the crotch
y
we live in a society shout out to the
guy showing he like human kindness in
this world we need that sometimes man
it's really really great but that guy
who went to the Super Bowl he was
talking about
I think the really cool thing was he was
talking about his military service too
like he served for this country he got
shot in the head and he said I am yeah
and he was saying like and you know what
if somebody asked me I'd do it all over
again I fight for my country again it
was [__] beautiful and then he made
his dream come true by taking him to the
[__] Super Bowl dude and the other
guy wants his dreams to come true his
own dreams yes
pretty strangers because he deals with
anxiety well
we're going to talk about something that
we were supposed to do we were actually
but the video got [__] up
um but we're gonna do it again anyways
and we'll do a better job so in this
video we'll we're going to talk about
our favorite our top 10 favorite
um uh things that we've seen this year
in terms of television and film and then
we're in a breakdown wakanda forever
yeah so this is a list of things we saw
not things we didn't see because there's
a lot we missed last year
um
so I wrote for number 10 Avatar 2.
and did you get to see it yet
okay for some reason I thought you were
talking about Avatar the live action
movie oh no and then I'm like hold on a
second and what the [__] are you doing
you better you better [__] break this
down I need to do a four pound break a
full breakdown of your analysis Avatar
the way of water no I didn't get to see
it okay well luckily for you it just
crossed like 2.2 billion so it's still
going to be in theaters it's still in
IMAX in theaters out there so you won't
miss it yet but you should definitely
check it out for its technical
achievements everybody everybody who
watched it they said that they were
amazed so this is what the general
consensus that I got from the film right
it's like number one watch it in IMAX
number two is that they didn't
particularly care for the movie that
much but they were just so odd at what
they were looking at yeah that they
didn't give a [__] yeah so like you know
you've seen us here we were always about
character growth character development
and all these things in the plot the way
it's structured and such and this movie
is very simple when it comes to that
kind of [__] but it blows my [__]
mind because I I do post-production you
know and there are things that I know to
my limit what I can and can't do and
when I see Avatar 2 it blows my [__]
mind because I know what it takes to
process [__] like even this okay so you
know when you're in shallow or you're
pretty close to the the top of the water
right but you're underwater and the
sunlight hits the water and and reflects
light on you right but it's got these
weird patterns from the waves and
whatever right that's impossible to do
digitally right yeah so you have to have
a fake mat of that
um that pattern and make it bounce and
[__] right and then lay it on top of
your model in on in water right but with
this film film they actually literally
do like I mean like Ray tracing is a
thing of video games and [__] they
straight up get real like light particle
effects into people though so that's a
huge achievement and water like it
generating Bubbles and [__] that's
another thing that blew my mind all the
water is fake
all of the oceans and everything on all
that is fake you gotta understand for
maybe a lot for a younger audience that
didn't really watch film in the time
that we did uh you guys will go back to
older film and you'll see people trying
to digitize things it's pretty bad but
it was mind-blowing to us at the time
because that's just what the technology
was at the time yeah we have been able
to see that progress right from the
Final Fantasy 7 block hands watching
individual digits fingers yeah right
from watching
um Toy Story
to watching Moana yeah right and then
you see the the
um and even then when you're talking
about water there's uh one of the
greatest achievements that they did in
Disney was actually uh from Frozen hair
hair individual strands of hair moving
yeah [__] crazy and then they went
crazy with hair in this video I think I
explained last time like in the first
Avatar film what they do is use cloth
simulator so it's as if you had a piece
of cloth and you cut it up and then they
overlaid it with Dread like Dread so
that's why everyone had dreads so it's
easier to simulate hair flying in the
air or whatever right but this time they
literally simulated every single strand
of hair on all these characters it's so
[__] crazy and we've talked about
this too where we say that you know
a lot of people who are on VFX they
don't ever get talked about and they
don't ever get their due respect yeah
and they go oh they get paid a lot they
get paid a lot for a good [__] reason
you have to understand how sometimes
boring their job is like Mariel was
explained to me like there are people
who are at Disney that if you ask them
what they did and you tell them like
specifically when they're doing um 3D
animated films it's something so obscure
and boring they go what did you work on
in the last five years he's like dude
see that clock yeah in that scene I did
the hands yeah right for [__] five
years but they didn't do the lighting on
it yeah they didn't do the Shadows on it
someone else has to do it because of how
much work has to go in through these
environments do a hundred percent and so
when I see you know when we hear about
things and uh specifically when it comes
to Marvel films that we see how trash
um a lot of the 3D [__] work is like
the digital the digital work it's like
they didn't give them enough time they
gave them such a short amount of time to
do this work and it represents them it's
like no they could do better they just
needed time to do it they need a time so
uh one of the things I was talking about
last time was how I saw it with one of
my friends and afterwards I asked her
how it was she said she liked it and she
was like I know you don't like it you
don't have to tell me I'm like why she
goes the whole time in the movie you
were shaking your head and you were
squirming in your seat I know it's
probably corny for you and I was like no
no like I have philosophobia I have a
fear of the ocean and deep Waters I was
freaking out throughout the whole movie
because it felt so real yeah like all
that underwater [__] was like even it
was displayed as magical but for me I'm
like this is a horror movie I could only
imagine dude because they especially
because of the technology and how real
it looks it must have been your worst
[__] night yeah because I saw it in
3D too okay that's even two times worse
so oh another thing you got like I said
you got to see an IMAX you should see it
in 3D too because it was shot with 3D
cameras actual two camera system for 3D
there was there's a a show on Netflix
where I don't know what it's about but
it was really really popular I think
it's still popular now uh not too many
people are talking about it but I didn't
get to watch it far enough to see what
the show was about but it was that they
were on like some type of like Titanic
ship
um but you you you get to see these
people in the boiler room and when they
open up this door you get to see the
ocean and they're talking and they're on
the ship and for some reason I didn't
put two into together I'm like wait
that's not the [__] action they're
not an actual ship they just have this
green screen room that's like a cyclone
like all the way all the way around and
so but it looks so [__] real uh have
you heard of the unreal Studio thing I
forget what the exact thing it's called
Muriel was talking to me about it
because that's what she worked on yeah
yeah yeah so the Mandalorian and the new
Marvel films are filmed this way where
they use Unreal Engine to generate the
backgrounds of these sets and now you
don't that's the thing A lot of people
are losing their jobs for set design
yeah and even locations kind of because
you could just [__] make it up and
have this 360 projection room and it's
connected to the camera so the camera
angle if it changes the background
shifts as well as it's [__] crazy
it's so crazy like
I love practical effects right but
obviously when we go into the realm of
superheroes there's nothing on Earth
that's gonna look like that they could
try to the best of their ability right
because even in in those sets they're
still needed but the background has to
be something Complete because they're
World building it doesn't exist like
this stuff doesn't [__] exist in this
world yeah or if you try like for
example right let's say they wanted to
shoot that that show that I'm talking
about they would have to risk the lives
of these [__] people on this boat in
this boiler room and open up no that's
not gonna happen yeah right but they set
design the ship somebody had to create
the ship to make it look real and they
had the back it was pretty [__] crazy
yeah so Avatar 2 is the basically what
you're going to see for the next decade
as far as like film Innovation goes
we're going to see some crazy [__] this
decade all right so moving on number
nine I wrote the north mid and uh you
haven't seen it yet right I forget where
it's streaming if either HBO or some
other streaming service but the north
men I said is apparently the original
Hamlet story the story of a king who
loses his throne to his brother who
takes over for him and now the prince
has to come back to his rightful place
Hamlet The Lion King black panther but
because this is the original North story
of where it came from it it uses that
story plot line
but at the same time I call it the white
panther okay because it is such a great
homage to White culture
North A lot of people are like this is
what we [__] needed yeah for real
though for real though I can see by like
look there's I I watch a lot of
different movie reviewers from different
backgrounds there's a whole lot of them
out there on YouTube and funny enough
those right-wing like movie reviews love
this movie and I'm like okay let me
check it out now it's great for in its
own right it's shot beautifully very
unique in its Style
but I think they were loving it for the
kind of weird reasons yeah yeah yeah but
it's like that's not what I agree with
but I could see why you like it I can
see why you like it but honestly in and
of itself it is a great film yeah so the
other one for me at at number eight I
said the bear I don't know if it's that
in that place for you but the bear is
the TV show on the Hulu uh we'll do a
full review but we keep pushing it back
and I have to re I'll rewatch that I
watched it like five times I think
around right now yeah so if you haven't
seen it you guys gotta check out the
Bears one of the best TV shows of uh
last year number seven I said nope
and we talked about it a little bit yes
right like we're talking about house in
like an allegory to this
our generation of society that just
loves trauma porn and we can't look away
and we have to capture
let's see and then uh six I said House
of the Dragon
because
I seriously hated the way Game of
Thrones ended uh season 8 was so whack
for me I just started watching House of
the dragon and already in the first
episode there was a scene I had a fast
forward through and it was when um she
was giving birth yeah I could not watch
it that part made me queasy so visceral
right just how much she felt betrayed by
him because they had to you know do a
C-section in the most archaic way
possible held her down and he's just you
could tell he like he's like apologetic
but his their air has to survive yeah
and I just I couldn't watch it I
couldn't watch that part it's a very
serious thing you could see what's going
on at the same time is that there's a
battle at where they're having the duel
right yeah and what is that the arena
look like oh yeah giant vagina yeah and
there's blood being spilled in and it
was like kind of back and forth between
the C-section and this [__] fight
that [__] killed me keep looking keep
watching teaching because that it's a
common theme
um for this uh That season of House of
the Dragon
let's see
uh five pray
the latest Predator movie Man we've
talked about this where like that was
actually one of the films that shocked
me how good it was yep because so many
reiterations of Predator has been
terrible terrible and so I expected
nothing out of it and so when my brother
turned it on it was during Thanksgiving
I believe I didn't want to watch it but
my brother already watched me wanted me
to watch it and I sat there I was like
dude [__] watch this [__] and I was
just walking by and I saw a couple of
scenes I was like this
[__] dough watched it [__] really
amazing and it's a waste that it
actually didn't get to go on the big
screen yeah because it would have been
way better I was so as when I saw it the
first time I was like yo these Vista
shots
the way they shot the Great Planes all
that I wish I was looking at this at a
50-foot screen amazing yeah it was like
so sad to see that it never came out on
such a you know a wide release but it's
such a huge property
I absolutely love it's one of my it is
my favorite Predator film I'm sorry it
does overtake the Arnold one for me
personally yeah let's see we move on
number four I wrote top gun Maverick
everybody loves that I didn't get to see
it he didn't get to see how do you see
it oh man amen if you ever have some
free time try looking it up somewhere
you gotta see it on a huge screen you
gotta see it with like the sound and
everything I feel like the next best
thing and we were talking about this
before we started this podcast was
um watching things in that Oculus sense
but there's there are products now where
it's just an OLED that's a sunglasses
yes yes and then they kind of
reverberate the sound through your skull
and I think that's like the closest
thing that you'll get the spatial audio
Yeah Yeah so it it it's weird it's
trippy that you can watch like IMAX
films at home yeah when I first used an
Oculus it was for this uh Jurassic world
type of thing and it creeped me up all
right I legit because of the way the
sound goes through your ocular bones and
stuff like that it sounds too real and
it creeped me out a bit I'm like this
doesn't look real but it feels real
because of how the sound is reproduced
in your head so I'm thinking like that
might be the next best thing dude you
gotta you gotta see it in in some kind
of format with the where you're immersed
in it yeah never watch it on your phone
yeah yeah
um yeah I saw it first in IMAX and then
I saw it in 40x you know what 40x is is
that where they spray water and [__] on
you yeah yeah and so when there's
explosions there's like bangs and then
when the the [__] planes are flying
left to right your seat moves and [__]
but then the one weird part was whenever
Tom Cruise was on a motorcycle
the [__] seats Rumble right but
instead of the seat rumbling there are
these two these cylinders these
individual cylinders poking you up your
[__] spot no probation
right on your [__] Gooch dude it was
like the whole theater went whoa I got
up off a new season for one guy in the
background yeah
how many times have you been here Ducati
yeah
so number three
Peacemaker and we did a whole episode on
that and we know that was my favorite TV
show to [__] John Cena and shout outs
to Aquafina and simulu booking a movie
with that man you guys in comedy in the
Futures and if it's an action comedy
with John Cena you guys are in for a
[__] treat hopefully it's gonna be
amazing uh I think it's gonna be real
good yeah yeah so let's go just because
I'm biased I mean I just love John Cena
and he he hasn't missed so yeah let's
see uh number two the Batman
man we've talked about this before we
did like a three hour breakdown of this
film because of how much we loved it by
the way that film was [__] like three
or four hours watched it twice yeah I
watched the bunch yeah it was that good
and then we lost the footage and um yeah
that wasn't gonna come out yeah and so
we can't do another four hour [__]
review on that [__] we broke it down
like scene for scene and all that and
I'm sorry you guys can't hear it but
then literally go ahead and search other
people other people's reviews yeah just
imagine us talking about it let's see
and our number one movie was everything
everywhere of course right and it's
killing it in the [__] it's award season
holy [__] they're taking it all they
took the Golden Globes they're taking
sag they take the Critics Choice well
deserved next thing now is the Oscars 11
nominations they're gonna win something
yeah so like best picture best lead
actress best supporting actress best
supporting actor and who would have
thought who would have thought best
editing best original screenplay who
would have [__] thought that this
would have been like the cinema cultural
like Phenom that it that it has become
right and you know at first the numbers
weren't that great on this film yeah
because people didn't believe in it but
guess what word of mouth Word of Mouth
everyone kept saying you gotta [__]
see this movie yeah I remember when we
did a review of everything everywhere
all at once there was a couple of
comments like I don't get what's so
amazing about this film I was like
that's because you are an idiot that's
literally my answer too like yeah if you
don't get it I'm [__] sorry you don't
even have to like the acting in it or
anything yeah but visually it was
amazing yeah I actually got hooked on
the movie
um from literally the first scene in how
he was shot it was through that people I
was like this is going to be a good film
right like just cinematography alone I'm
like
this is gonna be a good film the tone
and the [__] chaos that they
represent the [__] all of the
absurdity and the LOLs and wtfs and all
that [__] and all still culminates all
together at the end where it's like
I could be anywhere in the universe but
I want to be with here here with you
like it was such beautiful film you
gotta go out and see it and because it
got after the 11 Oscar nominations they
re-released it to 1500 screens yeah so
yeah go back out there and watch it on
the big screen you know I I actually
was taken aback at how good Michelle yo
is in just straight dialogue right
because we're so I'm so used to seeing
her in action films but when it was just
her speaking right I'm like she is one
of our best female actresses of all time
had no [__] clue literally had no
[__] because when you're in action
scenes you only get the corny lines the
one-liners the let's hurry up and get
this [__] plot moving so we can fight
again yeah and this one like
while having amazing [__] fight
scenes made each fight so [__]
purposeful and meaningful was Indiana
Jones
um a Spielberg film yes it was that's
what a spell were film yeah okay right
because we have Wayman yes right Alpha
Wayman got his first chance to be on the
big screen from Steven Spielberg from
Indiana Jones and he got to you know we
said this before a million times but he
really got to show what he's you know
where his acting level is in terms of
like how much he's grown with this role
right and originally that role was
supposed to go to Jackie Chan yeah right
how crazy is that yeah and then
um the Daniel Brothers took a chance on
him and it was the best move they've
ever made yeah because who the [__] else
could have filled that role you know
I think if Jackie Chan was it would have
been a worse movie it would have been
yeah I I it's like for all the films
we've seen when you try to go serious in
some films it's like I don't believe you
bro because what it would have been it
would have been a Jackie Chan film yeah
I mean it wouldn't have been the film
that it is now it would have been like
oh Jackie Chan's new movie yeah yeah
because it wasn't a Michelle Yo's new
movie it wasn't any of that [__] and I
think that's why it didn't get the
recognition that it deserved in the
beginning because it didn't have any
major Stars tied to it it was just the
film itself the biggest star that they
had was Michelle yo and to be honest
with you just be straight up a lot of
people didn't really [__] with Michelle
yo like that right they started calling
her the queen blah blah blah because of
this film bruh right but she was put to
the Wayside they just thought oh she's
the action star lady she's Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon but now they're
really seeing what she's about yeah you
know what I mean so on top of her acting
prowess she can also do amazing
choreography so good and she can [__]
[__] up for real she was up there like
she is Jackie Chan's beer yeah like and
since Jackie Chan we've had you know
we've had you know other martial arts
stars like Jet Li who did it with him at
the same time Donnie Yen who came out of
it a bit later but then as far as like
like female Asian acting starts coming
out of that school of Hong Kong Cinema
like Michelle yo is the [__] goat
yeah yeah it's pretty amazing so that
was our top 10 of 2022 sorry for the
procrastination it's probably March now
yeah right
um
yeah so uh we've been wanting to do a
film review of this and I hadn't seen
this movie
um you didn't see in the theaters I
didn't see it in theaters a lot of
people
okay here's the thing about this movie
right when we talk so now we're talking
about black panther black panther 2
wakanda forever yeah right
I always get a little weird about doing
um this film because it touches on
something that everybody's very
sensitive about anything that's very
culturally relevant towards like you
know black Americans you just have to
like it and if you say otherwise people
will get upset about it yeah even if we
do it from a film perspective right but
I I get it but I'm just gonna do the
reveal from what I thought from as a
film yeah if I were to give this just
straight up and we're going to break
this film down right
a lot of people came to me and said they
loved it a lot of people felt whatever
about it right but obviously they're not
going to vocally say it out loud they're
not gonna say it was trash exactly this
film was not trash it's not trash it's
not trash but I didn't love it
you know what I mean it's kind of like a
five out of ten seven a six out of ten a
six out of ten for me yeah I mean which
is not terrible right it's good enough
where I watched it twice and I didn't
feel bad about it right
it wasn't like uh some other modern
films that I've seen where I felt really
weird about watching it a few times this
one is I watched it and I wanted to see
what I liked about it and what I didn't
like about it right and what will break
down the film but Michael not Michael B
Jordan I'm sorry Chadwick Boseman
passing away was the biggest reason why
this film was not good yeah
um and because of that
off the bat like you
you feel like they're this this film is
fighting with itself for its tone
because
we get the bit of a meta catharsis with
how we feel the tragedy of the death of
Chadwick Boseman but they had to convey
that with the actors
like and they're grieving to chala's
death but in reality you see that
they're not acting they're talking about
Chadwick Postman yeah yeah yeah you know
and so the tone gets very somber and
very cathartic right yet it's still a
Marvel film yeah and so it needs to have
its humor
and it still needs to have its action it
still needs to have his big third act
you know fight battle like thing going
on and so it's still formulaic in what
it is but
um I think at the end of it for me I
looked at it like Matrix Four okay
like hey man the first one and black
panthers Legacy in the MCU for what he
was in with starting with Civil War the
first black panther film uh infinity war
and end game right and then because of
how like powerful of a character he was
in these films like we we expect so much
from the second one but he's gone yeah
right and so how do we deal with that
and
in that case it's easier for me to walk
in and be like okay what do they got to
tell us right
now while I respect what came before it
it was harder to digest this one for me
you know as far as the
how do I say this the presentation of
the film you know one of my biggest
criticisms of this well okay let me talk
let me tell you like
my biggest criticism on this film was
they didn't have a strong enough lead
yes
um his sister was supposed to be the
strongest lead here right but I
I don't know if that's necessarily her
fault as an actress right I don't think
that's what it is I really do believe
it's because Chadwick Boseman died and
somebody had to fill his shoes because
her character before was the comic
release yes can you imagine if rocky
rocky dies so Paulie Paulie
you know what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying right yeah I don't want to say
that is that a one for one comparison
but it's just like an example this is an
example because her character was very
important Sherry's character was
important yeah to the films but because
of what the character was and what it
had to take up in an instant to us it
didn't feel organic it felt very odd and
you know when we when I was talking
about first of all the trailer to Black
Panther 2 what kind of forever was
[__] amazing and I think that kind of
actually set me up for a little bit of a
failure too because it hyped me up that
trailer made me cry yeah dude I cried it
was crazy right and I
I actually thought the strongest
character in that film was two people it
was actually Angela Bassett but she died
right and then spoiler by the way this
is all spoiler review it's been out for
a while and it's also a VOD now so this
is a spoiler review for your suck my
dick
you know uh [__] um Angela Bassett
and the actress who played The Bodyguard
I'm forgetting her name Okoye right
she was so good right General yeah the
general she
was just such a strong female character
in this I actually thought that she
played a better lead than t'challa's
sister did you know it felt like she was
the most made to be the lead because of
her character's demeanor yeah
um but at the same time no she's very
loyal to the crown yeah that's in her
character as well yeah and so therefore
yeah it was everyone all eyeballs on
shuri yeah and that seemed to be where
the story was forced to take its place
right and it shows in the opening scene
it opens with
sure we praying to bust right she's
praying to a gun like please if you can
help me or whatever like I'll never
doubt you again yeah right boom gets in
the laboratory trying to synthetically
generate this flower that killmonger
[__] burned down in the last film
um she can't do it her mom walks in and
says hey your brother has passed right
and
for me I kind of saw that like
if
a character like t'challa is dying
um and those uh plants were burned down
you know then there was no cure then you
would expect Sherry with all of her
intellect inner genius to find the Cure
and then I and she fails she doesn't do
it and then I started realizing her
motive throughout the film
um that I missed the first few times I
saw it where she loses her faith and I
failed to see that first couple times
but that's my story in my life recently
and I was when I saw it from that angle
I started to be able to put myself in
shury's shoes better this time around
I feel like for me when it came to you
know Chadwick's death in that film and
how much it affected
um
shuri right I didn't really feel it
because it felt so disjointed it went
from that funeral scene and to her like
joking around with Okoye you know what I
mean yeah like
those things are very important if you
wanted to keep the theme of her sister
mourning the loss of her brother it
should have been more continuous
throughout the film right and you kind
of felt it towards the end where like
you felt it towards the end when she's
reflecting about her brother which was
very emotional that was actually
probably my favorite part of the film
yeah
um and then you know her talking about
how mad she is uh when Michael B Jordan
popped up right in the time when she was
getting the Black Panther power yeah I
didn't feel that at all I was like oh to
me it felt sudden I'm like I thought you
were just chilling like you know it
to your character to me didn't show a
lot of resentment you know what I mean
it just showed a little spurt but it was
so disjointed yeah so I wanted to know
what happened in the writing or
right right dramatically no no that for
sure happened because they for sure had
a script before that was gonna die they
for sure had announced Neymar before
Jack when Boseman died they for sure had
this whole storyline and all the the
pre-cinematics you know like set up all
those fights because you know how like
the director actually doesn't direct
those action fight scenes yeah those are
already done by like action coordinators
um but they had to change it because the
story had to change so much but then
for the sake of you know you can't just
change it completely from the ground up
because they've already been building
these sets you know and the action was
whack in this film by the way yeah yeah
yeah we'll get to that
but you know because everything was
already rolling
um they had to do massive rewrites and
still apply it to the main story they're
they're trying to convey yeah yeah and
so definitely you can actually see that
happening on the screen yeah like that's
what I'm saying it the movie had so many
different tones because of the weight of
Chadwick Boseman that's to touch all his
death like in this film it's like the
two two one and the same yeah
um because it's so meta about the grief
the grief yeah
um meanwhile having to be a classic MCU
film they should have just said [__] it
and kept up with that theme of
of just I think I would have really
enjoyed the film if it was
about shuri's struggle
losing her brother right and trying to
pick up the pieces and fulfill this role
that she can't handle right how much
more emotionally strong would that have
been right we can keep it within the
theme of paying respect to Chadwick
Boseman but it also gives like a good
footing and strong strong foundation for
sure as a character right or they don't
have to do the thing where they're in
the dorm and they have the girl who is
the [__] worst with them McGuffin
throughout the whole thing right
um Iron Heart yeah and I remember her
character's name
kind of a pointless pointless character
right she was there because she found a
way to find vibranium right which by the
way they could have just done that with
a machine
I said hey so it was like the the plot
goes that
uh
uh shuri basically loses her faith
because she didn't have the power or
even the genius or the intellect or the
technology she was powerless to save her
brother right so she loses her faith and
um
cut scene is the
the queen ramonda yeah uh Angela Bassett
she goes to the U.N Council in Europe
and France and the US is represented
there and in the meantime it's cutting
between this ship uh research ships
research vessel or something like that
and there are French mercenaries who are
uh what do you call it commandeering the
ship for whatever they're trying to
steal out of the ship maybe there's
fried brain name in there right but what
comes out is uh the door milage that's
what they're called right uh they say
the day they're protecting it and they
use that to show the UN that hey you
guys are trying to take our resources
you either trying to take vibranium from
us
right and you guys keep saying we can't
handle vibranium yeah when we've had it
for hundreds if not thousands of years
yeah right like classical uh they're
white people yeah white people think and
as the The Story Goes then
um there's another team searching for
for vibranium because what that's
setting up is that the rest of the world
since Chadwick boseman's character
t'challa in the first film
show opened up okana's borders showed
the world how much they're actually
worth show them how much vibranium they
have the entire world started looking at
wakanda as a Target and now they want
vibranium
and so This research team by the U.S
government military have this machine to
detect vibranium in the ocean floor
and uh they get [__] up by this
mysterious beings they come out of the
water uh they're blue
um
and they [__] their [__] up they kill
them all right and then this where it
leads to and it's a scene that I skipped
over
Queen ramonda and shuri are by the river
bed or something right and like what
content um
yes so in that scene
the queen is trying to show shuri how
when t'challa died when her father the
King tachaka died in uh Civil War then
t'challa died and there were all these
responsibilities put on the queen and
the weight of of the world on her
shoulders and how much she had him like
dig through all of that grieving and
pain to make sure that this country was
done right but she said she still found
the time to be by herself and reach out
to t'challa and she said he was there he
did come to me right and Sherry says
mother that was a construct of your
imagination your brain is just coping
with the trauma of our brother brother
dying right
and she's like well this is what we do
they burn
um the funeral garbs and then then they
can finally go and shuri is resistant to
that and in the middle of that where
Queen from under is trying to say
there's something you should know about
your brother
comes out the water and we see him
and he comes out the water and this
[__] has wings on his ankles
yeah and at this point in the film it's
like this is where they're asking you
suspend your disbelief this is here and
this is how it is how the [__] you get
there yeah right I mean apparently so
what we're understanding is that they're
from South America right it's a long
[__] way to Africa
right but okay comic book comic book
movie he gets there
and
he suspects that they are responsible
for this vibranian detecting machine
right and he says like if you're this is
your fault you're the one who told the
whole world about vibranium and now
they're after me and then they're coming
to my land right and reveals to them
like hey we have vibranium too it's not
just in your place
and from there they
they have a counsel in the thorn room
and [__] kamaru Usman is in the movie
he's part of the River tribe right oh
and he just stands there like Facebook
um so they argue and their plan is to
now get the person who invented this
machine find out who made it and then
bring them back to wakanda for I don't
know what trial or whatever some [__] or
for their safety
so
um it goes that Okoye
convinces the queen
to for her to take shuri with her to
Boston like hey let's get her out of the
lab she's been here for a year she's
been all that stuff and the queen
relents it says fine okay and then they
go to Boston where they encounter Riri
Williams
now Ruby Williams character
at this point as we were saying she's
the MacGuffin right and McGuffin is like
a plot piece like a infinity stone that
drives the platform it's usually just an
object some films use people as
mcguffins to help Drive the plot along
it's what both protagonists and the
attackers are after an object in the
film and we have America Chavez we had
this conversation about America Chavez
how when you make a character the
McGuffin they've got to be a core
centerpiece of this film they've got to
really mean something because they can
talk yes they speak they have emotions
and a great example of that is The Fifth
Element right uh uh multi-pass yeah yeah
right
um we didn't like America Chavez uh it
was as far as character McGuffin goes
she was kind of pointless we were saying
she could have just been a rock
um Riri Williams it's not that she could
have just been the machine itself right
um but her as a character definitely
felt like a shoe-in yeah she just didn't
belong yeah it just seemed like she was
Placer because they're gonna make a
movie about her uh she has she's going
to her her character is Iron Heart yeah
right she's supposed to be the Tony
Stark successor so I believe they're
making her own TV show
but they're also making armor Wars which
is a TV show it's like uh with
um
the other War Machine okay okay yeah
yeah yeah so it's based around the US
government using machines to start
fighting the Wars and such like that
um
I I get it because you want to cross
promote and such but it felt so
pointless like Black Panther in Civil
War made sense because of his
character's connection to Baron Zemo and
their motivations that they share
they're both out for Revenge right
that's why I keep saying like
I just didn't yeah we just didn't think
Riri Williams really fit into the
narrative what a waste you know what I
mean what a [__] waste it's just I
mean maybe a lot of people don't think
about it in that type of sense right
where they just kind of accept it but
when you watch so x amount of films it's
just so highly apparent it bothers me
you know what I mean it bothers me
that's what I was saying before when the
the valestorn when the curtains open and
you can see how the strings are pulled
you're like come on bro
yeah and then also to her machine thing
that was like yeah yeah so they they
tell her that her life's in danger
because she made the vibrania detecting
machine so other governments are seeking
her not only that uh name not more
Neymar is also wants to kill her and
you're not safe here you gotta come back
with us
and
um so they take her back to wakanda
they
well what they're trying to actually
they have a big chase scene they go to
her lab
and
they see she's a tech Genius of course
all that's given like she's she's out
there that's who she is
and then I don't know like
I don't know like I wonder like if I'm
being a hater or not I just did not and
like the scene I don't think anybody did
yeah I don't think anybody enjoyed that
scene dude there was just like also two
like
yeah
the action scenes in this were so
lackluster
especially for a superhero movie right
yeah and so when this film is not really
hitting the points of crazy action
scenes like really dope action scenes
and then on top of that not really
delivering on the story plot line I'm
kind of left with like what's going on
here you know I mean yeah give me
something to really walk away from here
um Shang Chi's greatest thing was the
action and the action was [__] sick
and and but what what you're saying now
though a lot of people have said the
same thing about the first black panther
yeah because he was coming off of civil
war Civil War had some dope crazy
actions dude great actions one of the
best Marvel films of all time yes
and then his next film was Black Panther
and I didn't enjoy any of the fight
scenes the scene where he's being
initiated as king I didn't like the way
it was cut I didn't like the way it was
shot I just didn't enjoy it dude they
had this one scene
um so
uh Sherry gets
kidnapped or she decides to go with not
more right right so that following scene
um
they run away from the cops but they get
caught by the [__] I don't remember
their name I keep calling them the blue
people the Warriors yeah they're from
talocon that's the city yeah yeah the
and
um they intercept them there's a fight
that ensues the general fights one of
their big General dudes loses the fight
and so then shuri voluntarily goes with
Riri because they're trying to take Riri
and they she goes with it did they ever
explain why she stabbed the [__] out of
those people and they just lived yes
what was it
um so they when they go underwater they
meet Namor and he tells his whole origin
story and he tells them about how they
are Aztec people right
yeah they were Mayan and
um they were struck by the Spanish
inquisitors and all the Conquistadors
conquistadors and all most of their
people in history it's shown were
literally wiped out because of smallpox
and it opens with the flashback of his
mom and she's clearly have signs of
smallpox
um on on her and their whole village is
dying right and so uh she's pregnant
with him
and and she's dying and then the shaman
suggests they drink from this plant that
came from the sky or whatever just like
um like the vibranium that fell into the
ocean like a piece of it that also fell
in wakanda helps grow this plant they do
the same thing they break it down they
drink it all of them drink it and
they're all cured from smallpox yet now
they can't breathe above water and they
they have to go into the ocean and their
skin absorbs oxygen right and so they
they set up a new civilization called
telecon underwater and this is where
Neymar was born when he's born they
really skip through it it's it's just a
montage where he's born with his wing
feet and then it's a split second and
they move on that's how he's born now he
he also explains that he's a mutant uh
where he's why he has the wings on his
feet why he doesn't age why his super
strength why he can fly and also swim at
Great speeds
um and so he's different from the rest
of his other people
and now his mother ages and she dies and
so him as like a youth
and her final wish was to be buried her
land yeah they come in so when they come
to land they see that their land has
turned into an entire Plantation and
everyone that they had known before are
all slaves now by the Spanish
inquisitors The Conquistadors all that
they've just been colonized
and because of that he just murders
everyone as this kid and his people they
all killed all the enslavers and all
that and he buries his mom and he got
that name from one of the Spanish
inquisitors like this priest who calls
him I can't say it the full term
or something something
yeah yeah but then that's that's a good
way to really because they called him
Namor right in the comics but they call
him Namor as in no love Yeah Cody Nola
Cody no love guard Brent yeah so he's
not not more No Love
so uh wait is it no level without love
without love yeah yeah
um
and what he explains is that
all of their people took the herb drink
yeah in wakanda one person the king
takes the year and so whoops sorry
uh so the the entire civilization of
people take this herb so they all have
this [__] power strength crazy
strength so when that was the
explanation of the general stabbing them
and killing them but they just got back
up and they healed because they have the
strength of the quote-unquote Black
Panther or whatever they call it yeah
yeah
and so subsequently
they talk like hey
Namor is explained to shuri like
we are just like you
we have this Society we have our people
he showed them their entire you know
flourishes flourishing land of happy
people peaceful people they play their
form of basketball
and then they they have their society
they have their markets they have
children and all of that you know and
it's like you want them to take this
away from us like we're on the same team
yeah we're on the same team
right and they try to come to an
understanding like look
he's saying I have to kill
this kid who made this machine this
vibranium detecting machine because if
she has this knowledge and knows how to
recreate this how can I trust it all the
nations are going to come after us not
only us you too you know and we can't
let that happen because you know what
they'll do yeah basically saying you
know what these crazy white people will
do yeah you know what the US government
would do because he's lived hundreds of
years and he's seen it over and over
again you know what they'll do they'll
come for your [__]
yet
sure he is still having a resolve saying
we can have peace let me take
you know the scientists back to wakanda
you know
then you know we can have peace
but there is an interruption right
um
the queen comes upon his Shores and
wants to meet with him and to talk so
when he's distracted to talk with the
queen where they're negotiating hey let
my daughter go
it comes to basically no more saying
you can't do [__] and if you try to do
[__] I'll kill you yeah and it's like
very antagonistic
right it's like and I'll destroy you
I'll destroy what what kind of all that
[__] you can't do nothing but what we're
seeing is that the queen is distracting
now more so that Lupita Nyong'o yeah
Lupita Nyong'o can come in and because
she was a spy in the past takes up her
spy
powers or not powers or skills skills
goes into and rescues shuri and Riri now
in the process she kills the guards
and so when Namor gets back and sees
that Sharia and
Riri has gone and he's been tricked he
is not out for blood yeah and now this
war isn't that is inevitable
and
what what happens is the talocon and
Neymar they invade wakanda and [__] [__]
up and in the process the queen dies
yeah right
and she dies saving Riri Williams
and she ties drowning because Neymar has
these water bombs and [__]
and they can't save her but they do save
for you Williams
and now because of that shuri now is out
for Revenge uh you know that was one
thing that didn't make sense to me was
her saving Ruby Williams yeah that that
one didn't sit well with me I know it's
supposed to show like her love and
reverence as as a leader but but why why
yeah because her Mission now is to be
the leader of wakanda to make sure that
her country survives right this girl is
the downfall of wakanda she's the reason
why you're having this Invasion exactly
I that part when I saw I was like
Bangladesh yeah I mean like what because
it also didn't show them have a a
developing relationship for her to even
step in place to do that so I didn't get
that part at all that was that was a
little weird for me I'm like hmm is
there something that we're missing in a
cut scene yeah because at that point why
is she so important yeah you have the
machine you know how it works
you mean you don't want Neymar to kill
her for the sake of I don't know
Humanity yeah
but you were the coin yeah I don't know
I I maybe we missed it I don't know but
I don't but
maybe it's important towards where
Michael B Jordan's appearance
comes in later because he makes an
argument for that case
so
because Queen ramonda dies like I said
uh shuri is up for revenge and she is
motivated to now recreate the herb one
more time but now she has a gift from
Neymar he gave her a bracelet that's
made out of the hemp or whatever from
the the plant
and he uses she uses their version of
the plant to synthesize their plant yeah
and um Lupita nyong'o's character is
there and she she knows the whole
ceremony of that and
it's one of those things like
the theme of what's Happening
shuri has lost her faith in bust right
she doesn't believe that she is a
science person now
that first movie when they do this
ceremony it was very
like religious Sacrament very ritualist
ritualistic all of that it was very holy
it was respectful all that
it was interesting to see shuri's
version of that because it's in her lab
it's all our synthetic herb it's all
synthetic right
and but it works from what it comes out
of it though she has her vision right
usually we saw t'challa go into the
ancestral plane in the first movie and
he sees his father right and his father
gives us an assurance that he is the
rightful King You know despite all the
weight of this on the shoulders The
Imposter syndrome is like no this is for
you and such and Sherry's expecting to
see her mom
right she calls out to her mom in the
whatever this plane is now
but it's Michael B Jordan
and she says how and you say everyone
wants to know how but nobody asks why
yeah and he says why are you here why
did you make the herb why did you take
the herb why are you here with me right
and and it's like he knows the answer
and she is in denial
right and he brings it out of her to
just say you want revenge just like I
did
you were saying earlier just be honest
yeah just say it let's say you want
likes for crying on on your [__]
social media just [__] say you took
this herb because you want revenge and
you want to kill
all right boom but she wakes up
and she believes it didn't work but uh
in her frustration she punches that
mannequin and boom she does have the
powers
right
now it's no longer as
reverent as it used to be right yeah
um and she goes to the
baku's tribe right yeah I forgot what
they're called uh in the mountains and
she means it's it's super glorious like
the Black Panther has returned and such
right but then like I said the the wind
gets pulled out of its sales
because she tells
umbaka like I want revenge yeah
I want to kill this [__] that
killed my mom
right and he's trying to like reason
with her like this is not the way you're
gonna destroy like you might kill him
right but everyone else also has these
Powers Yeah we can't win this fight and
she's like I don't give a [__] yeah and
she orders their army to go out and to
battle
and now we are at the famous Marvel
third act now this is what I mean like
how we're so dejected because we see
behind the curtains yeah every third act
Marvel third Act is it's gonna be what
it is yeah but this is why I love Civil
War
because they're big CGI set piece was
the second act was The Avengers fighting
each other right and all of that was
done and then the third Act was way more
impactful
so much more meaningful while Iron Man
and Captain America fought each other
even though it wasn't the big CGI show
of the airport scene it was just them
two not saying there was no CGI but the
them two fighting but that's such a good
comparison because honestly like if you
look at this film like the impact that
Civil War had because
Captain America represents a very
specific ideal right and then Iron Man
represents another ideal both in and of
itself comes from the right place right
and so when you see them battle you're
not actually I mean for me anyways it
wasn't watching two people trying to
kill each other because they hate each
other they're fighting for what they
believe in yeah we're trying to fight
for righteousness right yes which is
essentially what they're doing too not
more is fighting for his people and sure
he is supposed to be fighting for her
people as well right supposed to be
supposed to be it just it felt so short
of that you know it also fell short of
that too because like okay one of my
biggest criticism is this like so you
know
these people are
tens of thousands of people deep of all
black panthers right
you make only two suits
right the owl suit
I don't like this like to suit designs
what the [__] was that not only their
suits but the purpose of their suits
and I think we were saying why why did
Okoye and the other door milage get
these suits okay okay to to stand up
against
these underwater people because they all
got black panther power and I I saw it
kind of like uh Dragon Ball Z's level up
right everyone's gotta level up somehow
right you saw it even in Thor
um by Thor Ragnarok this guy Turns Super
Saiyan she's got the electric powers and
all that [__]
and so for I feel like Marvel might be
taking a piece of the idea that these
characters have to level up not just in
character but physically or whatever and
I'm saying that to say maybe that's it
but in reality what is it they're trying
to sell toys yeah
oh man that's such a good point you
can't just sell one black panther toy
that's right you gotta have you have
black panther and then you have name or
action toy but what if you had uh Okoye
action figure with the new you know suit
and then all of this and the [__]
karate chop maybe who knows like I'm
just like picturing this film right like
everybody knows like she well she
clearly as a leader doesn't give a [__]
about her own people right she goes it
doesn't matter if if there are a
thousand black panthers we're gonna go
fight them anyways yeah because I'm
gonna kill this [__] and we're
gonna go down right and then she only
gives two people the ability to fight
back well everybody else is fun like if
I was a part of wakanda right I would
have been like
[__] what where is my suit
Mutiny yeah so you're going to give them
this suit but you won't give it to me
like I was how am I going to fight them
like literally in the invasion scene
mbaku gets [__] up in slow motion he
gets
socked to hell maybe he needs a suit
strong as [__] yeah imagine if he had a
suit yeah he would have been whooping
[__] ass but
I said these third acts have been
pre-written years in advance
and so this is what's going on okay so
they have a giant Battleship I don't
know without guns
just a big ship it's a big ship
can is there an inside is there an
interior of the ship
yeah
no window I don't know okay uh
technology okay whatever
so
they had their battle the telecons they
jump on the ship and they fight
honestly I don't like the way it looks
didn't look good it actually was very
whatever yeah and also too one of the
things that I really disliked too is the
inconsistency in in character power you
just said they're all black panthers why
are they putting up such a good fight
yeah thank you if they're all black
panthers right how they describe it
seven of them should be able to kill
every single one of them that is the
strength of the herb I mean I guess you
make the argument that that's how
[__] badass wakandans are that they
can go up against these super out I
don't know [__] happens in MCU people
get nerfed people get way too powerful
okay yeah yeah [__] happens like that so
um what we see is that uh they have
um made this plan where they're going to
kidnap
uh not more into one of their ships uh
that's gonna [__] basically swipe him
up
um through the help with uh Riri
Williams okay so really we really we saw
her in Boston with her exoskeleton Iron
Man suit oh [__] she got an Iron Man
suit a great line
and then we see the full suit that she
gets to build in wakanda and she builds
it in a montage where she's using a blow
torch to cut vibranium steel apparently
yeah
anyway the suit comes out looking like a
[__] Power Ranger yep it looks so out
of place
now she's supposed to be the successor
of Iron Man but she looked like
a toy a literal toy and now they're
probably made that so they can sell the
toys I felt like a toy company designed
her suit yeah that's what it was such a
weird thing because listen I understand
maybe the argument behind that well
she's still super young so obviously her
her level of understanding when it comes
to stuff is hyper rudimentary however
she is now Tony Stark but with wakandan
technology yes and that's what you get
that's what you get like you know what I
mean that was very very weird and out of
place like I just
I didn't mention this part but one of
the things I hated too well we did kind
of mention it but I didn't give any
specific examples was the humor there
was one part where I literally heard
it was when he went if you go out into
the ocean your skin will explode your
blah blah blah or you could just wear a
suit I yeah I was like that was a
moment I'm like oh what was that really
misplaced joke I I thought about that a
lot right about Marvel humor
because the humor is written
in the script right
and now it's up to the actors to convey
that humor
the problem with Thor love and thunder
for me
what I realized and um I heard this
through Andrew Schultz it where I was
like oh [__] he that was a good point
was that
it's a comedy film right
Natalie Portman is an oscar-winning
actress but she's not a comedian
she had to act funny she had to act
funny with these funny lines yeah she
could not deliver not funny person she's
not a funny person
Black Panther
hired a lot of theater trained actors to
do humor to do humor this is why it
comes out corny that's why the delivery
is
delivery is terrible the humor was
really misplaced and I remember too even
in that
scene where they were picking a Riri in
the uh in her dorm I like her and I was
like that there's so misplaced all the
humor was really misplaced yeah you know
and sometimes with a lot of serious
films it's very important to have like
um comedic moments to kind of break up
the monotony of just this drab sorrow
like if there's no tension in a dramatic
film what do you fill it with
right yeah and if you can do it right
like
um humor and that's why we're like we
love these Korean films that may be
super serious they could be horror films
but for some reason they're [__]
hilarious yeah right to fill up that
time to fill up the mood like if
nothing's happening and I think the
biggest difference between that is that
the character in in and of itself
doesn't have to be hyper funny they
don't have to be comedic it's the
situation and the writing that makes it
hilarious right how the character would
react to the situation that is what a
sitcom is exactly the situation happens
what what Kramer do
what would Seinfeld do but in this one
it's like well you you just gave him a
comedic punchline why they must deliver
yeah it was just really weird for
namor's character to have that weird
punchline at that moment and I was just
dumbfounded I'm like [__]
was that
Jesus Christ man what the
you know and this kind of goes back to
my criticism of
um once again you know rest in peace
Chadwick Bozeman but really his passing
away the adjustment they had to make for
the film in order to fill this Mega
Superstar role putting put to put that
on the shoulders of Sherry was really
sure he was really hard because even in
that last fight scene it was with
between her and Namor it was so
lackluster yeah it just wasn't good I'm
like this is supposed to be the third
Act
this is an amazing part of the film
where you get to see [__] go down right
which is very very marvelous we could
see this happening but if you're going
to deliver it the way that we expect it
to you better [__] deliver it yeah
and I was so disappointed yeah I mean
there are two points of well three
important points of that final fight
um
as I said before
they captured
not more into their ship and they have a
microwave built in it yeah
anyway
so
they they they they [__] heat them up
and it's taking the moisture out of him
so he can he can't breathe
um he he [__] the [__] up where he he
Spears the ship so it crash lands
um thankfully or luckily or conveniently
it lands on a beach
and so the fight happens between where
she's trying to keep him from getting
back into the water
uh fight happens and in the climax he
[__] takes a spear and stabs her
right in the gut you were saying about
that gut Punch Yeah I was like the [__]
you were saying how it went right
through her spine yeah I like when I saw
that [__] I was like
she he severed her spine it's dunzo
that's instant that's paralysis she
can't use her legs nothing yeah and all
of a sudden she pulls it out and does a
backflip yeah
twisting back flip completely fine right
I'm like this is interesting right
um
so that happens I mean that's one of
those things I hate when I say that
about a movie so that happens
that's where I'm like ah [__] it's it's
losing me
anyway so that happens
um
and
she
one UPS name or by blasting the jet
engines on him Burns him up by grilling
him grills him and now she takes the
spear and has it at his neck and she's
ready to kill him
and I was trying the last time we talked
about this too we were like
where did her mom come from
wait I thought that happened when you
took the herb but somehow okay okay but
what happens as we're watching in the
edit
she has the Spear to his neck and then
she starts getting flashbacks
the way it's explained is that in her
there's I've heard other critics say
that this is her most vulnerable moment
this is her Mo this is the Pinnacle of
her decision making and therefore that's
why this happened and I don't buy it
it just happens right
so she gets flashbacks of wakanda
her Society her people the the the the
children the women the men in the
streets
um
they're them living in harmony
and then it is juxtaposed with the
people of telecon underwater who also
have their men women and children who
live in a society in peace
and then her mom in the ancestral plane
tells her
show him who you are
this is a line
from
black panther one when t'challa is
fighting umbaku for the seat of the
throne right and it's part of the
they've been fighting at the waterfall
and it looks like t'challa is going to
be bested and then in slow motion the
queen says show him who you are and he
gets this second wind and headbutts him
and [__] wins the fight
now this happens
in this third Act
and this is where we were saying it just
happens right
and for me because of the placement of
this happening I think it's a deus ex
machina
is the it is a story beat it is um
I mean um deus ex machina in films is
like okay dodgeball one of the most
famous examples of it is that they beat
the Ben Stiller's team right but he's
like hey man I could still [__] buy
your [__] gym and close down and all
that [__] so what I lost this whatever
but then a treasure chest shows up right
and it's full of fight money 500 5
million dollars right and all if you
notice on the treasure chest it says
deus ex machina that is a story uh
why do you call that a formula or a like
a story solution to conclude plot points
and poppies at the third act just to say
just to wrap it up right honestly it's
just lazy storytelling yeah and in
DodgeBall they did it as a as with a
sense of humor like a joke as a joke to
say we need deus ex machina to finish
this movie because it's so stupid it's
so stupid that he gambled money and won
five million dollars so that they can
buy his gym instead that's why it's
called deus ex machina it comes from oh
amazingly old Greek and Roman Theater
plays right when they do mythology plays
and such right
and at the time
when they're wrapping up their story
there was a thing they would call deus
ex machina the god of the machine where
on the stage they would you know use
ropes and pulleys to bring down this God
character onto the stage and save the
story and wrap it up and finish it
because a God intervenes right
that's what this felt like
Queen Ramona from some reason comes into
the ancestral from The ancestral plane
to Sherry to say show him who you are
and she gets Humanity
she gets altruism she no longer wants
revenge yeah
I'm gonna call that deus ex machina I I
I can't say any other way
you know like
once again
I know a lot of people who really
enjoyed this film and it kind of goes
through that idea of why people enjoyed
like shanxi a lot right there's there's
like emotional notes that hits you from
a cultural perspective right yeah
but even even with that right
you can't get away with like lazy [__]
like that
I mean yeah and if anything else where
did the mercy come from
that's what I'm saying like my biggest
issue with this film was character
consistency like it just a lot of things
just doesn't make sense and it goes back
to what I said with her shuri being the
main character it's like you didn't
invest enough into her for her to have
the motivation to do the things that she
does to do the right thing at the end
yeah why did she do the right thing at
the end because she did everything
for the sake of Revenge
but where and why okay so Civil War
same thing happened to t'challa
when he saw
Baron Zemo sitting there like
yup I did it I destroyed the Avengers
I did I enacted my revenge I was
successful don't forget people forget
Baron Zemo won at the end of Captain of
Civil War he made the Avengers split up
this is what he wanted internal battle
and t'challa seeing that from the
outside the third party he says
vengeance has come soon the both of us
you know and we and he saves this guy
from suicide too
they tried to parallel that here because
she says the same exact line
Vengeance has consumed us
but it didn't come from the same place
yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is why we did not enjoy it like I
get where it comes from but why
you it's it's it's the problem with many
sequels is that you must carry the Beats
of the predecessor yeah but why and also
I don't agree that her saying Vengeance
has consumed us I don't think Vengeance
consume not more at all his motivation
was saving his people yeah right people
so Vengeance consumed you [__]
not him yeah he he got he sent his
message out he warned you about the the
consequences of what was going to happen
if you chose to prioritize yourself over
the the safety of both your guys's
Nations if you chose to do the selfish
act this is what was going to happen
Vengeance did what didn't consume him he
but if he's on the ground like to just
speak for yourself [__] Ben just has
consumed he goes actually it's just you
just you I'm actually trying to do the
right thing thirsty yeah can I get some
like water please I don't know why he's
Mexican now
foreign
she saves his life
and they she asked him to yield if you
yield I will
I will protect your land
you know I will be an ally we will make
sure your people are from the people
above because we are above right and he
yields
and
it was very triumphant moment in any
case even though it's a bit convoluted
they get back to the battlefield or
battle Waters
and
um the theme song plays and he calls out
the telecon and they yield everybody
else yields as well
um and Cherie stands triumphant
so
oh the whole time we didn't talk about
the colonizer Martin Freeman oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was a whole
nother B plot where
um
he was the point of contention where we
see him as part of the US government
right
um his part in the CIA was
colonization basically uh where
you bring chaos into a state what's that
called a destabilization stabilization
that's a specialty and so what we see is
the US government because he has
connections to wakanda to ask him to
destabilize wakanda and what we're
seeing is that
the bigger enemy in this film is the US
government
right
and so
in the one of the last scenes we see one
of the talocan girls asked me more why
did you bend the knee to this girl and
he talks about how they might be the
most powerful on the surface level
right but they need us too and so when
those white people attack wakanda
they're gonna call us and that will have
the upper hand then right and just wait
till then
um
as
the the story progresses uh there was a
whole thing back at that waterfall and
it was a bit of a comedic beat
um sure he's not there for the
coronation
she goes to Haiti Haiti where Lupita
nyong'o's character is
where the whole time apparently well
well uh shuri gets her piece finally she
Burns her funeral garbs to pray over her
brother uh you know move on from her
brother's death and such finally and
then the post-credits scenes we see
Lupita nyango his character we should
know her character's name by now but
Jesus had a son
to Saint
and it is revealed that his real name is
Prince t'challa the son of King t'challa
which is what uh Angela Bassett was
trying to tell her right
I am so [__] sick and tired
of characters in The First Act who say I
need to tell you something and then my
main character I don't need to I don't
need to hear it whatever and then
information never gets passed down
they Marvel did it again yeah Ant-Man
did you see Ant-Man too no I don't watch
it because a lot of people say they
hated it right so it's got like a
[__] 40 something percent
I saw it and I didn't think it was that
bad honestly it was one of those things
you know the way you felt about love and
thunder I felt so bad Quantum Mania okay
I didn't think it was as bad as people
said it was it is dumb
but hey there were moments where I
laughed my ass off that's what love and
thunder was for me I was just like this
is a dumb stupid movie
but they do that again
where one person has this information
and they could have [__] just heard
this information but they're like
there's no time we gotta do this so they
don't say it and it's like who in the
real [__] world in any case or any
manner knows that information is from
like very important when it needs to be
done
in a storytelling device in a plot where
someone was withholding information like
there's got to be a good reason right
yeah so I'm seeing this like why are you
guys withholding this information for
sure she is suffering yeah she is angry
she has so much pain and hurt and all
that
like for her to know that uh part of her
brother lives
changed the whole plot of this movie
also too why didn't they bring that boy
over yeah
yo I've been to Haiti it ain't great
yeah I promise I bet wakanda's way
better that's what I was wondering too
it's like what was the reason for them
to hide him in a third world country
there was something they mentioned
expositionally how
uh t'challa didn't prepare anyone in one
conda for their death but he did prepare
Lupita and his son for his death
and so he set them up in Haiti something
about how he didn't want them at the
funeral because it would Expose and then
it could have been Game of Thrones or
whatever so they're like you're you're
safest bet right now is he fight for the
throne and obviously he's in the air so
this child would have to fight it got it
got it got it got it got it
that was the I'm gonna say excuse I'm
sorry if that has to be an extra
Exposition point in a post-credit scene
then it's like
I
like I said this this movie needed its
rewrites because of Chadwick boseman's
deaths and this is what we're seeing out
of it these
screenwriting no-nos kind of happened
because there's ain't no time
things happen and you know changes the
way you kind of tell the story yeah and
I'm not sure if other people felt this
about the the film as well but it seems
like they were focusing a lot on these
one-liners to hit on like cultural
Nuance for people to be like
um you know so for example when they
were at the UN and she was saying like
why are you telling us that we don't
that these the the vibranium is so when
we had it for thousands of years right
and that's actually like I'm not sure if
they did this on purpose but that's an
Ode to a Minister Farrakhan or Minister
Farrakhan
um said uh he said this very poignant
line right he goes white people are
scared to give us power because they're
scared that we will do what to them what
they did to us yes and it was an Ode to
Minister Farrakhan in my personal
opinion I think that's what it is so
that's like those moments of oh [__]
god oh you know and then there was that
joke where this is the first time I see
a colonizer in Chains uh yeah a lot of
like focus on these one-liners right
because it worked in the first movie
yeah Hollywood loves doing that that
joke killed let's say it again in the
sequel please
please that's not how jokes work though
yeah and this is what happened with like
love and thunder right uh the Ragnarok
before that I didn't like it because of
the excessive jokes but a lot of people
enjoyed it and because of those jokes
right so they doubled down on it in
[__] love and thunder to the point
where they all they cared about was
one-liners lots of jokes do you know
what I'm saying yeah because the reason
why I was very critical of of Ragnarok
was because of the incessant jokes that
uh Chris Hemsworth had to continually
make right it was like there wasn't a
moment where I could just sink in and
get into the war that they were trying
to create in the film because they're
kept on doing these record scratch
moment jokes with them right you know I
I feel like they had to make that
because of the way the first two movies
are yeah yeah first two movies were
Shakespearean plays basically you know
on theater actors but cribs Chris
Hemsworth is a funny guy yeah you know
he's great at improv and they they for
Ragnarok they wanted to you know dive
deeper into those abilities that he has
and then I felt like oh that works for
Chris Hemsworth that must work for
everyone in the MCU and it doesn't yeah
it doesn't that's why like that movie
was just a bunch of one-liners and you
know like I said again I walked into
that film prepared knowing what it was
going to be like and it was that's why I
just was there to laugh yeah and then
what people were talking about oh the
story I was like yeah I thought of
course I agree with you 100 but I just
knew that I was like you know what I
think we're just gonna be here to laugh
you're like I'm past the [__] yeah
because I know it's [__] exactly and
they had great funny ass moments but
they definitely wasted a villain because
um Christian Bale was amazing yeah he
was so good I was like yeah but it was
very out of place because he was so
theatrically amazing for the rest of the
tone of the film but did it make sense
you're gonna kill any Gods yeah
they just kind of went past it yeah
they're like oh by the way he killed 30
Gods yeah we're not gonna see it
okay A Word of Mouth bro yeah because by
the way I killed them cool
yep we're gonna see how dope this dude
is yeah nice reputation that's the thing
reputation on screen is hard to
translate you have to build it yeah you
know so um yeah these were the things
like
I was seeing like I said because
I didn't like it the first time I saw it
and then the subsequent times I kept
seeing it made me like I said Do The
Matrix Four I appreciated it more and
more because of the basis they had to
try to cover yeah
um while at the same time having to deal
with this tragedy you know with Chadwick
Boseman passing away in the middle of
before they could film
and so
for me like I said I
I love black panther one I absolutely
believe it's it's best picture
nomination at the Oscar is well deserved
it's one of my favorite films yeah
because of its metaphors and allegories
to what it's trying to say today it was
one of the films that really helped me
because I I'm a film buff we love
receiving information through the medium
of film right and it helps me understand
people's feelings emotions and
experiences
black panther one for me was one of the
first films that was like put yourself
in our shoes right and that did it well
because it painted a picture of wakanda
as something that's not so far and
different from the America we were
living in at the time that it came out
in 2016. yeah
wakanda
as it comes in is this amazing
technological Advanced Land with all the
greatest wealth and greatest military
power and such
but in order to preserve that
they have to preserve that through walls
building invisible walls
right and constantly saying wakanda
first
wakanda is their highest priority for us
that they are a conservative Nation
there's no apologies about that in the
movie right and us as audience we accept
that this is amazing
this is you know the the Africa that
could have been without it slavery and
colonization and stealing of resources
and land and wealth all that because
diamonds come from Africa lithium comes
from Africa all the resources we need
but why don't they have the wealth
it's the I that's the idea of wakanda
today right wakanda great again yes
exactly and to keep preserving wakanda's
greatness is their MO
and how they do it
but how do they do it
through lies and killing
that's how they preserve the LIE um
the king killed his own brother to
preserve the LIE
that's how important it is to them this
wealth is that's how important it is to
them and that system
created and raised an amazing King such
as t'challa and the Black Panther in
this amazing Nation but guess what the
same system that builds greatness
created the killmonger it created the
Vengeance it created the anger it
created
um basically the hurt and pain that the
rest of the world actually feels that's
why when the Black Panther one first
came out what was everyone saying yo
Michael B Jordan has a point yeah yeah
which is why he's one of the greatest
movie villains ever come about because
it's like wait a second even us says
audience he's right
every point he's fighting for so are we
fine we want that too yeah except this
guy is willing to kill still and Destroy
yeah he kills his girl that came along
the way he even says I killed my own
people
I killed my own brothers and sisters I
killed the marks on his body are
representative of each person he has
killed to make his way to wakanda you
know you have like thalassophobia I had
that [__] when I see dots that's oh that
[__] tryptophobic
tryptophobia that she [__] killed me
[Laughter]
that [__] yeah oh
[Music]
precisely like
and this is the whole the two sides of
the same coin the Chala and killmonger
are the same people they're the same
character but they were raised in the
same system under two different
circumstances
you know and Kim killmonger
his
his purpose
was right
right his reasons were righteous his
methods were wrong
t'challa and wakanda
right
the ideas were right
right but the methods were all so wrong
right
and so
killmonger's biggest Mo his whole
purpose is I'm going to now take your
wealth and your weapons
and I'm going to give it to all the
black people all across the Earth and
we're going to take over this planet
right
what is that the Black Panther Party of
the 1960s and 70s
is what they wanted so wrong
they wanted rights yeah but they weren't
given to them they were tortured
murdered and killed and thrown into jail
in prison and wrongfully accused for all
these things and they were like you know
what then then we need guns yeah then
we're taking up the Second Amendment and
what happened anyway Ronald Reagan
governor of California took away their
guns yeah the reason why California has
strict gun laws is because Ronald Reagan
enacted it against black people that's
what happened to the Black Panther Party
in reality
and now this is what Eric killmonger is
the representation of the tale of two
black panthers right
and
he wants to Annex the world he wants to
colonize the world just like white
people did to us and he learned that
through the CIA that's what he was doing
he learned the ways to destabilize other
states too it's like now I'm doing that
here
and what did t'challa have to do
when he lost that battle and went back
to the to the ancestral plane he pointed
his fingers to his ancestors and told
him you were wrong yeah
you were wrong what you did was wrong
could have saved that boy we could still
have this wealth and save the rest of
the world and all the people across the
globe he says you were wrong and
t'challa has a change of heart this is
therefore why he starts bringing Aid to
the world and tells people about who
they really are and see those are the
moments that I was expecting out of
black panther 2 because I was crazy and
so was I yeah and you know there are
there are reasons to be critical of
black panther one like the CGI was fun
Jesus Christ they said we said many
things about the CGI yeah but you know
that scene was so very iconic especially
when he was talking to his father right
because he's coming coming into
realization that this world this hero
that he has who is his father who was
his perfect man he has to confront him
yeah you know and he has to make these
things right right so like I remember
that scene when he was arguing with his
dad and he goes you were wrong that
moment in that theater everybody felt
that [__] right if I was waiting for
those moments in in wakanda forever and
everything just felt so lackluster right
like I said like we talked about the
spirit of his throat so I do the right
thing right just cause just just because
just because like all right
yeah you know what I mean so like at
least t'challa in that plot Point went
back to the ancestral plane because they
saved that one last flower yeah
you know in this point it was just it
happened
when you've already set it up in the
first film you can't change the rules in
the second film exactly and then you
lose the consistency
now I'm going to say the allegories are
there in this film we mentioned it
earlier uh on the last time we tried to
record
um
the telecon represent the Latino
population of this Western Hemisphere
right
telecon represents t'challa
the old t'challa yeah right
the man who would do anything to protect
his
his land his country his people
right and so what he's doing isn't
necessarily wrong because he keeps
pointing the finger back at them at the
people of wakanda you do the same thing
yeah you would do the same thing
because these white people are after our
resources
also to the thing I didn't really like
was you know the conclusion was she says
I'm going to protect your people
you were gonna protect them but they're
gonna kill you yeah they're way better
than you I think she meant
diplomatically with the U.N okay because
I was like you know I think they could
[__] all you up yeah why are you trying
to lie to kick it just yeah just be
honest just say the UN yeah just try to
be all hard I'll protect you I was like
do you see what the thing too is like
you know when they flew back right and
they're standing in front of everybody
all the wakandas got their ass kicked
and they're at the edge I was like bro
you could have just went up to him been
checking kicked her off that thing
you've been all good
but
so and then his masterful plan is like
listen now we're gonna wait I'm like you
didn't have to wait you guys won
[Laughter]
well
this one it's hard to put the story
together because it feels
very convoluted yeah and it's
it was a story that was very hard to
tell because of Chadwick boseman's death
yeah yeah yeah rest in peace rest in
peace but
um that's the reality of what we got out
of it and this is the product we
received what was that message is a
thing too especially because the first
one has such a strong message right so
the message I felt like
I thought was
Latino and black Alliance
that Paulo Khan and Neymar represents a
Latino community
because we don't talk
a lot about
um their people's destructions as much
as we do about slavery and what happened
to Africa and such in the slave trade
when we do know like yo Latino people in
their history was decimated
decimated 90 of their population gone
due to the disease brought upon by
colonizers they enslaved them as well
Christopher Columbus [__] [__] up
whenever he landed in the Americas he
enslaved them cut off their noses ears
and arms to you know get obedience out
of them he raped them all of that too
but then they don't get that recognition
for that suffering instead there's a
Christopher Columbus Day yeah yeah yeah
yeah right and so that empathy isn't
given to the Latino Community isn't it
and this I think this film is through
Sherry showing that the black community
giving empathy to the Latino community
and saying we need an alliance
because you and I were fighting for
resources but guess what the government
the US government and those white people
they want what we got I felt like that
was kind of like the story being told
yeah you know it's interesting because I
there's something that's
coming about on Twitter right now which
I don't understand why this is coming
back but
you know ever since the pandemic and
obviously within the pandemic there was
the BLM thing and everything else and
everything for some reason for me as I
take a step back and I look at it and I
was just thinking about this the other
day
I feel like we're all just being [__]
with to hate each other you know you
know and there's somebody else that's
not it's outside of us that's like
whether it's the government there's
something bigger at play here or they
just want everybody to hate each other
and they want our our country to be
destabilized it feels like that so much
right where even to the point where
people know this and they still don't
care like you do understand this is not
conspiracy theory either like it's out
there a lot of the stuff that you see
when it comes to hate and propaganda
it's Bots and people know this and they
still ignore it and they they're arguing
with Bots yeah you know and it creates
this hate within everybody the one of
the things that
and it feels like America is being
attacked the most right because we're
the ones in power and so everybody else
in the world is just laughing at us so
one of the biggest things that everybody
says outside of this country is like I
wonder why Americans are so obsessed
with race right they go they're so
obsessed with race all they do is talk
about race and you know and our point is
it's like well you know for the Black
American you know something tragic that
they went through but people outside
this country is like do you know that
we've had those atrocities too like your
problems aren't we're not diminishing
your problems we're saying that these
are issues and stuff that you go through
but you speak about your problems as if
nobody else has problems outside it's
the most important issue of the entire
world yes that's why people ignore
you know other countries Holocaust and
they think that there was only one
Holocaust that ever happened during
World War II yeah and you know when I
speak about this tuber you know I'll
give you guys a great example
you know of us us two here as you know
we're Korean Americans we're Korean we
experienced our own Holocaust right like
our grandparents got [__] up like by
the way this wasn't that long ago yeah
it really wasn't my grandparents who
just passed away what seven or eight
years ago both my parents spoke Japanese
yeah because it was a language that was
forced upon they were trying to worst of
course they were eradicating our [__]
culture we had to change their names
yeah they had Japanese names you don't
you know my my aunt in Korea my oldest
aunt she doesn't have a Korean name
she's Japanese no cesco
yeah
because it was that was she was born
she's like 87 yeah her name is Tesco you
know what I'm saying like her culture
her name was eradicated her name she
doesn't have a Korean name a [__]
trippy is that [__] you know what I mean
and that's why you see black people with
the name Smith Jefferson Washington
exactly these are not their original
names they they they had a uh a
religious cleansing yeah and they they
forced upon their slave master's name
and this is what they have you know what
I mean that's why they call it they say
that's my government name yeah I mean it
comes from that type of stuff so like
when I see this stuff on Twitter and the
thing that I was talking about is like
we're having arguments about racism on
Twitter where
um like for example there's been a lot
of Clips going on Twitter right now
where a white person is getting beat up
by a Mexican person or a black person or
whatever you know what I mean or an
Asian person yeah
and then people like dude this is a
racial attack they go no that can't be
racial because uh a black person is
beating up somebody who is white so it's
not racist right and because the black
person has no quote-unquote power and so
they're redefining what racism is and
and they're like and you know people are
arguing back like no it's you're
convoluting two different things you're
talking about systemic racism and just
racism in general societal races exactly
like hey you can't come to my party
because you're white that's racism
that's racism like definitively that's
what racism is racism you can't say
that's not racism because the white
person has power over you what the [__]
what are you talking about exactly but
you know and you can't even argue with
these people because you'll bring up the
Merriam-Webster's definition and they'll
just say no that doesn't make sense well
just because you feel that it doesn't
make sense doesn't mean that that's true
I'm not disagreeing with you with in
terms of systemic racism but watching
somebody belittle somebody else mistreat
them beat them hurt them try to kill
them because of their ethnic background
is definitively racism so why are we
defending this you know what I'm saying
well it's I defend this because they did
it to us in the past so I'm gonna do it
now as Revenge
how do we heal from this how do we
become better from this type of stuff
you know it's just a very like I've just
been I thought about it all day
yesterday just reading the things that
people talk about and see right and I'm
not talking about people who are in
within my cereal these are not the Bots
yeah and they get caught up in this
maybe it's because these are people from
LA right because Los Angeles people feel
that wokeism is a thing to do and it's
going to give them lots of likes so this
is what they become obsessed with it
becomes a part of their identity but I
don't understand like how people can
live in this world and keep their sanity
right right and we're
what the the message that black panther
is trying to convey is the alliance
factor of it right is that
like we have the same resources actually
we both have vibranium whatever
and it's I feel like vibranium is an
allegory to just that it factor that
black people have vibrating everybody
wants a piece of it piece of it
something that ethnic people have that
white people lack and they must have a
piece of it give me that ribs baby yeah
how dare only people of color have this
we gotta have a piece of it you know and
then they make it their own as if it was
never a black thing as if it was never a
Latino thing
um and this film is kind of conveying
that that they're just colonizing [__]
whether it's culture but then they're
using vibranium as that allegory of what
do you why do you know what you want to
call it the Mojo or the flavor just that
Essence awake what makes them who they
are it's part of their identity right
and their wealth and their growth right
like they don't even want them in power
right because like they said that you
know no no one person should have this
power because of what you can do with
this like yo [__] we've had this
power for thousands of years and we were
living perfectly fine and we weren't
[__] with you but now it's a problem
it's a problem because wait historically
from what we know you can't have power
yeah it should be ours yes it should be
ours because we don't trust the
difference with jealousy like oh I hope
our country gets to that point where we
have that kind of GDP no it's like War
Envy we must have those resources and
only one person can have it and that
only one person has to be us the the
United States so look what happened to
[__] Iraq yeah one of that oil baby
this world is so much is so controlled
by like things that I feel like people
just don't really care to think about or
talk about right they
they just want to argue and Americans
are getting exploited so hard it's
unreal dude yeah and it doesn't matter
what's pointed for a feeling yeah our
feelings yeah because apparently now in
this generation Our feelings dictate our
dollars and so that's what's happening
is that the corporations and not only
that just anybody who's trying to make a
buck hits your feelings like do you
understand how weird it is now that you
can be somebody who is contributing to
society you have worked hard
you've got this degree you work in a
career in a field that is very necessary
for this world you make a 100K and then
you see this girl
and this guy
doing a tick tock dance and they make
three times as much as you can
her girl says her toes on only fans and
then she makes 10 times 10 times the
amount that you do and so it also like
devalues this country a lot right like
what is now your worth yeah like what
are you not even now at all it's it's
just a weird space to be in like when I
see what kids value when I see what even
not I'm sorry let's just rephrase it
what adults and people just value in
this country alone it's very very
[__] odd because the response to to
when people who I believe are a little
more level-headed and it's like listen
let's let's focus on things that matter
right and the only low level
response that you get is what's the
problem
like and they'll explain the problem
right that you're just a hater this is
why you are a [__]
and we're trying to have a conversation
with somebody like you who just don't
you just don't think outside of yourself
you don't think about the future it's
not the future it's not the big picture
it's me my feelings right now at this
moment and what you just said yeah and
we'll talk about more of this depth in
another episode but like I put up this
tweet the other day where
even when I say this right and I always
feel like I wonder what people think
about me when when I like terms like
politically right yeah because I feel
like I'm
pretty in the middle you know what I'm
saying like I have a lot of like liberal
ideals a lot of like conservative ideals
too I'm just like right in the middle
um but you know I saw this video the
other day of it was
um just a group of drag queens dancing
for a bunch of elementary students and
I was like why
like why did you set up this event
you know I'm not even speaking about
this from a moral standpoint and that's
you know what that does to kids
psychologically because I'm not who
knows we don't know I don't know but why
but why what was the purpose of this I
don't understand I think it's the
normalize it just to be like hey we
exist yeah you could just Exist by just
talking to them what's with the dancing
what's with the music what's with the
drag queen like them with their ass
cheeks out half naked like I don't
understand that part yeah I'll be honest
I didn't look into it I didn't know it
was like that oh yeah they were they
were they were doing drag queen like
[__] [__] and I'm like that's cool
for adults it's your choice yeah but
you're why didn't you just have them
come in and talk to them yeah because if
you're trying to normalize it I think
they did it on Nickelodeon that where
they had a lgbtq plus parade Animation
Show and for that I was like okay that's
a that's a great way to normalize you
know that the fact that these people
exist
but then I'm saying that too where it's
just like
um because imagine this too right like
and I want to say this
uh like what if for example like you
just brought a bunch of male go-go
dancers I mean they're naked right but
that's their profession right it's like
let's normalize it this is a job
like I wouldn't be okay with that either
time and place time and place on their
18th birthday on their 18th birthday
yeah I'll take you to a gay strip club
right or something you know what I mean
like or like a male go-goed female go-go
dancer it doesn't really matter but why
is somebody who is doing this like I I
never looked into it right yeah but from
what I heard I thought they were just
story reading they were reading so
that's drag queen story hour that's a
little different okay so this is an
actual like track you'll see it on my
Twitter it's like uh they're [__]
straight up dancing right like they're
doing the the drag queen performance
stuff and like the the dude is like
topless tassels you know [__] like that
I was like this isn't drag queen Story
Hour right okay this is a little
different this is a little weird you
know and I even understand for some
people who have a problem with drag
queen's Story Hour too I get why they
might be uncomfortable there are people
who are a lot more conservative you know
and that [__] with them a little bit I
get that
um I don't really have an opinion about
that I don't so I don't know but that
was odd for me I'm like you guys could
have just brought them in to talk to the
kids what's with this part about it why
are they over here just yeah you know
I'm like what the [__] because then it
becomes sexualized now it's not just hey
I'm a drag queen you know we're a part
of the society
then it becomes really weird I'm like
you you didn't have to go that way you
know what I'm saying like what if for
example like for you know uh what does
your parents do it's like oh I'm uh I'm
a I'm a performer I dance right let me
show you
you know like no you could have just had
them come in right I don't know I
thought that was a little odd right yeah
I I it's probably like
you know when we're trying to normalize
like ideas and such like what we were
saying it's like time and place or age
time and place I think things are really
important yeah because like look if if
that look
like Boogie Nights right you know that
that movie uh Mark Wahlberg where he's a
porn star that movie is explicit oh dude
I don't know because extremely well made
Heather Graham had her and I thought
Heather Graham was so cute now that is
an amazing art form and also an uh um a
unique look into this industry that not
many people look into and there's no
other movies about such a thing you know
which is a great way to normalize a
culture as such but we should show that
the kids on rainy day schedules what I'm
saying would you show this to kids
though no I don't think so and I think
it's fine to show but not the kids yeah
not like look I'm not a advocate for
don't say gay that's [__] to me but
then again like there are things like
wide like is it important in your kid's
life it's an important to their kids
life to be exposed to this yeah and you
know I've had a couple of conversations
with people about this and
um
yeah we were just kind of going I was
just asking why and I'm glad that they
weren't upset that I asked why because
that's usually the response that I get
when I ask why they go well why the [__]
not I'm like well this is not a
conversation now because I just asked
you why you know and then I think what
they they were like you they're like
well drag queen story I was like this is
a drag queen Story Hour like let me show
you what this video is they're like what
the [__] is this I'm like yeah what the
[__] is that I was like I thought I was
going crazy and I was laughing because
I'm like is this real yeah or is this
like some kind of weird like AI
propaganda [__] because it didn't
feel real at all it felt like um like a
setup yeah you know what I mean but then
I thought it was real like what the [__]
was this school thinking it was cool it
was like in a school or something you
said it was like a private event no it
was like a bunch of little kids it would
look like in a school so I was like oh
I'm like what the [__] is going on like
I don't think that's appropriate I don't
know yeah I don't know what everybody
thinks but well guys I think I think
we're like you know Back to Black
Panther the Black Panther I don't know
how we got to that point get there but
yeah um the
they there was an allegory in there it
was a bit it it had a a lot of external
things to have to tie it in because of
Chadwick boseman's death but you could
tell that there was a a big picture
allegories like they had in the first
black panther
they had one and they had to also tie in
the fact that the biggest main character
died in this film yeah and so the film
Lost itself in two different tones and
two stories that they were trying to
tell at the same time yeah got lost in
that yeah well guys
um let us know what you thought about
Black Panther if um we bought any new
Enlightenment to the film for you
um I feel like we did a
better job about explaining this in the
for in the second time the first time so
it was it's a lot better now yeah so I
actually prefer that it's back at the
old Studio I did a poll asking people
like the old studio and it was
surprisingly overwhelming the old studio
so I guess we're gonna keep it here I
like it here too it's a lot more
comfortable a lot more casual it's homie
it's very homey plus we get the drink so
um you could catch ggs brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m
um streaming Thursdays on my YouTube
channel uh Thursdays at 7 00 PM YouTube
live uh typically twitch on Friday but
not sure if I'm gonna keep that up I
kind of like YouTube live a lot better
uh you could catch Ed at edparkvp and
also Bible study at Momo's is his uh
podcast check that out and then it's
going to be out in Seattle so he's gonna
be gone for a bit I'll see you in a
month guys and then we will see you all
next time peace bye